it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is a sharp
knife the secret behind keeping a sharp
knife sharpen it before and every time
you use it first grip the steel really
come to about holding still imagine
you're holding a tennis racket or you're
playing squash he's really comfortable
with it now 45 degrees confident grip
confident grip of the knife this is the
butt of the steel really important to
keep your fingers behind there you never
grip a steel with your fingers over that
because the knife comes back in you've
just lost a finger always grip behind
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade over steel stroke and we start
from the bottom to the top so there
across there across slow strokes over
the top of the steel and then come back
in to me then back and release it's so
dangerous working in the kitchen with a
blunt knife you could cause so much
damage working with a sharp knife is ten
times quicker and more efficient now
that's ready to start chopping
- stop your chopping board rocking or
slipping a great tip is to simply wet a
kitchen cloth kitchen paper or tea towel
and place it underneath now
you can chop with confidence start
squeezing that garlic out I want the
flavor coming out beautiful pierce that
open squeeze it in